أنا كاتب أفضل
أنا فنان أفضل
أنا إنسان
جاء إلهامي بسبب الضرورة
أنني تناولت وجبة كبيرة لقد كسرتها ابنتي
منذ بعض الوقت ،
لذا قمت بتحطيمها لأنني لم يكن لدي
أي قاطعة
وبدأت  لألصقها أنا أحمل
نفسي ، لا أعرف بيتي من
قبل الزوج ، قد يعجبني أنه
لا أعرف
، وبعد ذلك عندما عاد ، أحب
ذلك أيضًا ، لذا فعل الشيء نفسه على
اللوحة الخشبية  وفعلت نفس الشيء
مع المرآة وأخذت
المنتصف لتتعرف ، كلما كانت القطع أكبر كان
ذلك أفضل حتى تتمكن ابنتي من
الكتابة في القطع الكبيرة
التي تعرف أنها سهلة بالنسبة لي لتنظيفها
ولكن بعد ذلك في 79 عندما انتهيت من
كل شيء
بدأت أرى أن هذا المكان
يزداد سوءًا يومًا بعد يوم ،
واكتشفت أن النمل الأبيض يأكل بيونسيه
الآن ، وسأواجه مشكلة كبيرة الآن ، وسأضطر
إلى إخراج كل شيء والبدء
مرة أخرى من
خلال وجود الثرمايت على الأرض والجدار السفلي
غير قادر على الخروج
لأنني أستخدم الفسيفساء الآن
يمكنني تصميمها وعلى الموظفين
رسم مباشر على الحائط لا أرسمه في
أي
مكان وبسبب هذا كل غرفة
مختلفة
وكل غرفة هي تجربة
[موسيقى]
مغامرة
أجنبية
يمكنني إخبارك بها عن ساعة واحدة في
سنة واحدة وستة أشهر
وثلاثة  أسابيع وأربعة أيام ،
حسنًا ، يمكنني أن أخبرك بتقدير
حوالي 20
طنًا من المرآة حتى الآن
كان الأمر يأخذني عندما كنت أعمل
كرهت ذلك
لأنني أعني مليئة بالأسمنت وأشياء من
هذا القبيل تعرفها بالفعل تحب أن تكون
جميلًا كما تعلم  لذلك كنت مثل ،
لكن من فضلك لا تأخذني الآن ، فأنا في حالة من
الفوضى ، ليديا إذا لم أشكرك ، فلا
أحد يعتقد أنك فعلت ذلك
واستمررت في فعل ذلك
[موسيقى]
في
[موسيقى] لقد
منحني هذا  الشعور بالإنجاز
أعطي الإنجاز
بأنني أوقفت النمل الأبيض لأن هذه
كانت طريقي لإيقاف النمل الأبيض
ولا شيء آخر
وفعلت ذلك لقد حققت ذلك